because the houses are set up the house
is a bunch of Trump haters they put
every Trump hater on the committee the
same old stuff they frankly want our
situation to be unsuccessful which means
death which means death and our
situation is going to be very successful
the House has put on a committee an
oversight committee of Maxine Waters and
Maloney and the same people and it's
just a setup but doctor about you will
be testifying in front of the Senate and
he looks forward to doing that but the
house I will tell you the house they
should be ashamed of themselves and
frankly the Democrats should be shame
because they don't want us to succeed
they want us to fail them so they can
win an election which they're not going
to win but they want us to think of it
they do everything they can to make
things as bad as possible and right now
the stock market's way up everybody's
excited they're going back to work
safely but they're going back to work
we're opening up our country again and
this is what we're doing and I'll tell
you the whole world is excited watching
us because we're leading the world what
happens should never ever have happened
China should have informed us that they
had a problem